There's a chain reaction to it,
just like craft getting caught and getting a blowjob that shut down business.
All you got no United States.
Nobody walked into a spa without wondering whether or not existing of her and
your name was going to be blown out on them.
Isn't that crazy?
But here's the thing,
they,
they miss,
they get this guys,
there's a video of this guy.
Do you want a massage?
So they've got video of it.
Right?
And at the end,
the girl jerks,
I'm off.
What if she didn't jerk them off?
What if she just gave him a massage?
What kind of a fucked up invasion of his privacy if he just went in there to get
a massage.
Right.
Or was everybody just getting jacked off?
I would imagine when you sent him a plea deal to drop the charges.
So I don't know what happened.
He ratted everybody out.
He's like,
I need to stay up Marie Brown kids.
Well,
I gotta tell you,
you know,
I was a so loan some,
I took some comfort there in my lifetime is if Paul Simon ones wrote and,
and um,
yeah.
Okay.
I'm not,
I'm,
you know what,
I'm not going to say it because it's just not worth it.
They're worth it.
It's not,
it's not that everybody seems to be perfectly aware that they could be washing
your feet.
Yeah.
And you know,
and that's fine.
Yeah.
Why is it,
um,
that a guy like that would go to a place like that?
Like he's so rich.
I,
you know what,
he has a guy,
if you don't have a guy who should get a guy like no further,
a cleaner look,
look no further than,
uh,
and this is ever,
everybody's going to realize that you out fading.
My memory is now.
But,
uh,
the English actor that got caught with the,
yes.
Elizabeth Hurley's husband Hugh Grant Grant,
right?
Yeah.
Look at you grant married to the hottest woman on the planet at the time,
right?
Ruthlessly hot.
Yeah.
Amazingly hot.
You look at it,
he wasn't married jewelry either.
Right,
they're boyfriend,
girlfriend.
And,
uh,
and even I couldn't understand that.
Right.
I mean,
cause I,
I,
you know,
I've,
I've been with a couple of hot chicks before in my life,
but this was,
he wanted to freaky.
Yeah.
He and I,
you know,
and I get that and it comes back to that appetite thing that guys have.
You know,
I've gotten a hand job from somebody and I admit this and it was the best sex
I've ever had in my life because it was somebody that was at number one.
It was a great massage and then this tantric thing going on and,
uh,
and,
you know,
and it,
but it was fantastic and,
and pricey and,
uh,
and,
and it's free most anywhere.
And that's in Vegas is legal as it can be.
You know,
they have milking tables that have a whole,
your Dick Hangs through and,
uh,
they do milk people table look it up.
They got him for the guy.
If he lives in the stomach,
well,
you don't have,
you got somewhere to cracks.
You got to get somewhere to put your heart on.
Felt like he just laid on your back.
No,
but it makes more sense.
Hygienically to have like a hole in the bottom of the table.
It'll be on the screen,
I'm sure soon.
That is ridiculous.
And I'm not,
all I'm saying is that in like in Canada,
they,
you know,
are the most of the rest of the world.
It's,
uh,
getting a tug is really not considered a crime of any kind whatsoever,
and is harmless.
And who gives a shit and why is it okay to massage your feet?
But it's not okay to massage.
I would rather massage my dick then my own feet.
I would,
and I prove it on a regular basis,
regular basis.
I think the problem really is sex trafficking.
That's the problem.
[inaudible] Tom era,
you know,
that's the worst thing that I can imagine.
But,
but,
but I,
again,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna go there because it's the most horrific thing.
You could have the most horrific thing you can imagine taking sides.
Just finish watching that series of bad,
uh,
taking Madeline.
Uh,
and,
um,
and so I'm like,
I just can't even,
that,
that I would,
you know,
I would support any,
anything,
any way,
shape or form to have it stomped out,
spend billions of dollars,
put boots on the ground,
you know,
stop it.
If you can,
in any way you can,
women who are trying to be legitimate sex workers,
whether or not you think that's the thing they,
you know,
then it doesn't matter what I think it is a thing,
go down to go.
I just went to Amsterdam before I took my mother to Barcelona because I wanted a
little three day stopover,
uh,
before I spent eight days with mom and Barcelona and,
and their signs don't take pictures of our sex works that our sex workers,
not sex with our sex work.
And,
uh,
I mean,
they,
they totally own it and go,
hey,
this is not a bad deal.
You know,
it,
uh,
you know,
your,
you know what you're qualified to do,
make French fries.
Yeah.
Or it turns out you're super hot and,
and you in our country,
you can have this job or in la or in this country,
you're going to have that job.
Just not everywhere,
but it was only a couple spots in this country,
right.
In Nevada and Nevada for I think that,
and I don't even know.
I think just the bottom.
I think that's it,
but it's to me,
here's what's up my real life and this is important.
Okay.
Um,
I played Vegas a lot,
right?
I'm 10 weekends a year at the Mirage and marijuana is,
uh,
is legal recreationally now and they have the biggest dispensary in the world.
Was he like,
oh,
like it's like a universal made it or something.
You know,
I went in there,
it was fantastic.
And uh,
prostitution is legal.
You can get a drink of liquor 24 hours a day,
seven days a week.
And I realize that I'm a law abiding citizen.
I hear when I'm standing on this part of the United States ground,
I don't break any laws at all.
I can be free.
That's why I feel so good when I go to the Vegas.
That's why people go,
do you like Vegas?
You get tired of it and I'm no,
no,
you don't want it.
Cause I can breathe deep motherfuckers.
That's why I could be who I am.
Yeah.
I can do it openly.